مشاهدينا معنا من الخرطوم يوسف عزه
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
اهلا بك معنا في العربيه استاذ يوسف بدايه
الان وبعد اسبوعين من هذا القتال العنيف
هل ما زالت قوات الدعم السريع تعتقد بانه
يمكن حسم هذه المعركه عسكريا
طبعا كما هو معلوم القوات الدعم السريع لم
تبدا الماركه ولم تخطط لها اصلا ولما لم
لم تخطط في يوم من الايام لمواجهه الجيش
السوداني او محاربته لانه القوات الدعم
السريع هي قوات نظاميه والجيش شريك
بالنسبه لها وتعمل مع الجيش في تنسيق دام
قوات الدعم السريه بماريكا في صباح 25
بقياده الدعم السريع بالطيران
هذه ماركه فرضت علينا
وتخطط لها قوات الدعم السريع كل العالم
يشاهد على مدى اسبوعين ببساله حققت فيه
انتصارات كبيره وسيطرت على مقارات كبيره
للجيش وعلى التقرير 90% من الولاده
الخرطوم على كل الجسور على الطرق القوميه
قاتلت قوات الدعم السريع دفاعا عن وجودها
ودفاعنا خياراتها
عندما تتحدث وتقول بان قوات الدعم السريع
سيطرت على نحو 90% من ولايه الخرطوم منذ
بدايه هذا القتال ويعني نرى معارك كروه
فرم معارك شوارع ايضا بحيث انه تخرج
فيديوهات لسيطره جانب على مرافق مهمه ومن
ثم يخرجون منها عندما تقول سيطره يعني هل
هي قادره على يعني التمسك بهذه السيطره
دعني اقول جميع المواقع التي استلمتها
القوات الدعم السريع سيطرت عليها منذ
اليوم الاول للمالكه حتى الان لم تخلى اي
موقع سيطرت عليه القصر الجمهوري بيده مطار
الخرطوم بيده اذاعه الاذاعه القوميه
التلفزيون في يدها
موقع الجيات في يدها قاعده الاولياء
العسكريه في يده كل المواقع التي استلمتها
قوات الدعم السريع لم تخليها ولم
تتردد ابدا في الدفاع عنها كل الطرق
القوميه هذه المعارك معظمها يدور باستمداد
الجيش بقوات في الاقاليم ما دام السريع
يسيطر على كافه الطرق القوميه طريق
بورسودان مدى طريق مدنيه طريقه طريق
الشيال الشمال طريق كل الطرق التي تؤدي
الى الى الخرطوم يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع
القادمه من الولايات تصطدم بارتكازات
والدعم السريع والدعم السريع يدافع عن
نفسي اذا يسمح باي قوه تدخل من الولايات
لمسانده الفنون في الخرطوم هذا هو هذه
المعركه التي تدور نعم طيب كان هناك ايضا
تصريح لقائد قوات الدعم السريع لقناه بي
بي سي قال بانه هو مستعد اوقات الدعم
السريع مستعده للمفاوضات شرق شرط وقف
اطلاق النار ما هي الخطه السياسيه الان
لقوات الدعم السريع في حال بالفعل كان
هناك يعني جهود وساطه ناجحه
لعقد مفاوضات
[موسيقى]
هذا اختبار كلام قائد الدعم السريع هو
اختبار قدره البرهان ان القرار في يدي
قرار
في خمسه هدى في ايقاف
وقت اطلاق النار والطيارات تقوم الشعب
السوداني كله يشاهدها وتضرب وتدمر
هذا هذا الشرط واضح جدا من غير قوات الدعم
السريعي اذا استطاع البرهان والجيش بيده
وليس بيد جهات اخرى ويستطيع وقت اطلاق
النار
لانه يعني اذا استطاع البرهان وقوات
القوات المسلحه كانت في يده وليست في يد
جهه اخرى ماذا تقصد
هنا انا اقصد ان البرهان فشل خلال خمسه
هدى فشل بايقافه
عبرنا عنه في اكثر من من
ان البرهان مسيطر على الجيش نحن لدينا شكل
الذي يدير المعارك ليس البرهان
اليوم الاول الذي اتخذ قرار الحرب ونحن
عبرنا عن ذلك بصراحه الذي اتخذ القرار
الحرب هو شلول هم النظام البايت هم الضباط
الاسلاميين في الجيش قال غايه القوات
الدعم السريع صراحه من يريد اطلاق الحر
الحرب فليتفاوض
هؤلاء هم صرحوا صراحه
وجميعهم ما زالوا يشعرون الحرب ما زالوا
يطبلون لها ما زالت حتى حياه علماء
السودان التي تتبع لهم والتي كانت بوغه
كانت هي اليه النظام في التبريد لكل
جرائمه في دارفور في كل مكان اصدرت بيان
وانحازت وحل الدعم دماء جنود وضباط الدعم
السريع هذه حرب واضحه معالم حرب لم تعد
سرها يعني التيار الاسلامي في السودان
والحركه التي يقودها على كرسي وليس كل
الاسلاميين التي يقودها لكرتي لم تعد لم
يعد سرا انها هي التي ترتبت كل شيء
استاذ يوسف تقول بانه يعني البرهان لم
يستطع ان يوقف النار
خمس سنن قبل الان فشلت يعني هو القوات
المسلحه وعلى ما يبدو قائدها البرهان يريد
حسم هذه المعركه في اقرب وقت ولكن واقع
الامور كما راينا في الاسبوعين الماضيين
تشير بانه يعني هذه المواجهه العسكريه قد
تطول هل تستطيع قوات الدعم السريع الصمود
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست مليشيا انها ليست
قوات مضره انها قوه منظمه تتبع خطط عسكريه
مرتبه تعرف بها اين اين تقف واين تضرب
وكيف تحافظ على على على مواقعها لديها
الان عادات كبيره جدا اعداد كبير لا يعني
استولت على المخزون الاستراتيجي كله للجيش
استولت على دياب معروفه انها تدفع الحربي
استورد على مواقع اخرى لم تعلنها لديها
سيطره كامله على على بوصفات الجيلي
تستطيع ان تصمد لسنوات وليس ايام وهذه
الدعم السريعه الان في موقف ليست ضعيفه
الجيش هو الذي يخسر الجيش ليس لديه قناعه
بالحرب ضباط كثيرين جدا سلموا انفسهم
بالدعم السريعه جنود سلموا انفسهم هنا
لك من قادر ارض المعرفه وخدع بالزتي
دبابات في يد الدعم السريع مدافع تقييد
الدعم السريع الدعم السريع في موقف يمكنه
استمرار الحركه افضل مده ممكنه وحتى الان
الدعم السريع كل القوه التي قاتلت لا ليست
تساوي 20% من قوه الدعم السريع ما ز
هو حول الخرطوم لم تدخل المعركه حتى الان
وماذا عن الشعب السوداني يعني اذا كانت
تستطيع قوات الدعم السريع الصمود لسنه كما
قلت ولكن واقع الامر بانه الوضع الانساني
سيء جدا ومن يعاني وسط هذه المعارك هو
الشعب والمواطن السوداني
نحن هذه الحرب كما قلت لك لم نتخذ غرارا
وندافع عنه وايضا ندافع عن خيارات الشعب
السوداني
اكبر عمليه لعوده النظام السابق عرفوها
البنادق للسيطره على السودان نحن سنها
وهذه قضيه الشعب السوداني التي عبر عنها
في ثوره ديسمبر الملايين خرجوا
واسقط النظام في يوم 11 ابريل هذا الذي
يسميه احمد هارون الانقلاب هذه ثوره شعبيه
شهده كل العالم هذه خيارات الشعب السود
ويجب ان يتحمل هذه المعاناه هو ضاب الجيش
لم يقاتل في حروف خارجيه 40 سنه يقاتل في
شعبي طيب استاذ يوسف ماذا بالنسبه لجهود
الوساطه مبادره ايجاد اين وصلت
منظمه ايجاد هل وصلتكم اي يعني
نسخ رسميه هل تناقشون اي جهود وساطه الان
نعم هنالك وساطات كثيره نحن لدينا لجنه
مختصه بعمليه الدراسه هذه الوساطات لدينا
وساطه من
امريكا ومدعومه من السعوديه لدينا وساطه
من الايجاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره
صديقه ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن
لسنا دعاه حرب ولا نريد استمرار الحرب ولا
نريد معاناه شعبنا لكن نريد مبادره تضمن
ان يكون هنالك حل جذري للازمه السودانيه
هنالك حل يؤسس لسلام دائم يهزم العقليه
التي تقود الحروب وظلت تقود الحروب منذ
الخمسينات هذه
الحروف يعني الشعب السوداني للسلام والامن
ويعيش حياتي
هنالك معاناه
شكرا جزيلا لك يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع كان معنا من
الخرطوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات